[Music]
Jessica you look Sensational look at you
you like you gotta you got it going on
like all for you it really yeah I'll
take it let's get out of here
okay I see what you're doing that's
strike two what is this a baseball game
I don't see any any balls around here
except for ones you know that
you ski
I do ski yeah yeah I imagine you'd
probably ski in a kind of tight little
outfit
oh
well like like this I just go like this
you wear that skate dude see in my mind
you do for sure yeah I don't think you
should be changing stuff around I'll try
not to no don't no just keep feeding it
yeah
oh donut man yeah yeah
you talk to Donuts when you eat them I
like my Donuts so fat their holes are
closed
make me creepy I don't know
um no actually they it's more like a
Bikram Yoga really to keep them nice and
warm what does that tell you it tells me
you know what Bikram Yoga
you do Bikram Yoga I used to have you
ever done it no I've thought about it a
lot though well when I say thought about
it
thinking about you doing it no they if
that's the hot a hot yoga where you get
all sweaty and kind of oh yeah like that
right
that's exactly what they sound like
hi Secretariat
[Music]
I think he's very excited to see you hey
how are you I'm good come on warm you up
I I find the undergarments to be like in
this dress they were the most they were
the most difficult thing to navigate
really what what are they like
don't wear these then were there I don't
know but I they're fancy though I like
them I feel like they should stay on oh
yeah I like that you know
you know what I mean
stay on this show stay on the show yeah
yeah absolutely what were you thinking
oh come on come on get your mind out of
the gutter well here's the deal right I
have a cat I know
okay
well I'm not surprised that's what I'm
doing what are you trying to say I'm
saying when I look at you I think yeah
well it's so many words yeah
I like an SUV right to keep your cats
you keep my cat in when we go to the vet
you go to the vet a lot
is your [ __ ] sick all the time
okay
[Applause]
oh you must what's wrong is your cat
she's fine oh okay good good I was
worried you I thought you left her in
the SUV no that's bad you must I forget
her I'm trying to do my non you know
previously car that I own but I've
scratched out of it so
wait a minute before before you bleep it
man look at her
just give it what she wants I believe
the male heterosexuals are more
attracted to slightly larger females
okay yeah
you got any cookies back there yeah yeah
you want some tea
it's true though I have to tell you that
every time I eat myself up a little bit
your husband my husband frisky yeah yeah
that's right he gets a little Hands-On
right I love it's great you see what
happens is I think dress designers are
like no you've got to be thin so that
the clothes look like that but you see
men who are not involved in dress design
they're not caring about the clothes
staying on
exactly you're like Baby It's You know
and if it's too uncomfortable take it
off yeah
that's right but the shoes stay on is
that is very good yeah
that's very good come on yes but you you
look great in them thank you yeah I just
look fat and you smell great and um I'm
sorry if I'm a little creepier than
usual I have a mustache oh no
you know how you can tell if a man's got
one testicle bigger than the other how
he walks in circles
don't all guys have one testicle
slightly slightly but if it gets too big
you just walk in circles all the time
or you have to go and have it adjusted
by a special doctor that ladies don't
know about
but now we know the Secret's out yeah
that's I'm gonna tell everyone well
you're going to tell all the girls
there's a special bold doctor yeah
yeah they'll cancel the book clubs for
that one
I think you're just sitting close
because it's so cold in here
no I I mentioned this a few weeks ago in
the show I like to keep it cold in the
studio
foreign
[Applause]
that's the reason why that show was so
popular because those guys would come
out with those tight sweaters on and you
know that
the guys would oh yeah I mean the girls
yeah
you know I'm European the guys and the
girls would come out wearing the
sweaters no I said did you enjoy the
show Friends
I'd love that
you didn't have a Rachel haircut though
I have it now no no no no I had a Rachel
haircut you did
on my chest yeah
Yo Gabba Gabba um the Bubble Guppies
nope oh yes yeah yeah they're creepy
creepy a dog fish oh no I can't take
them that thing with their butt keep
doing that keep doing that
[Applause]
right
[Music]
there's there's our Bubble Guppies right
there
did you do the uh the uh the Christmas
Carol movie with uh Jim Carrey as well I
did it's a that's an animated movie
though it's motion capture motion what's
that
it's actually your movement all of your
acting is seen and they paint over you
meaning you know I said can you give me
really large breasts please and they
said yeah we'll just paint those in
post-production I said great that's
great
um
my wedding rings really burning
Sensational may I say I like I really
like your dress it looks like it's going
to be see-through and then oh
that's for later
I mean
[Music]
[Applause]
I see you've cut your hair is that
indicative of some emotional turmoil
a crisis I don't know okay
I see have you been experimenting with
the
non-routine sexual behavior for you
love triangles and kissing and kissing
partying and yeah
you know what that is
show you what that is kissing you say
yeah what form does this kissing take uh
it's with the lips they lock together
and sometimes tongue sometimes tongues
sometimes tongues
no I'm not familiar with this at all
okay
baby right
yes
no no good
here don't don't lean
you scooted and then leaned a little bit
I did and then and you're leaning again
you're leaning again now you're leaning
and tilting
[Music]
all right well we're out of time anyway
foreign
internal medicines to all her work is
done indoors
internal medicine that means like it's
all organs no she doesn't do hair
no it was and knock it off you're just
showing your teeth for money
thank you very much Nick
um
yeah
you help yourself go on have a good time
you're like on my top five list oh
[Applause]
top five but you're a happily married
woman yeah and you're happily married
yes yes
um so what do you mean you can't have a
list all right would you so much tell me
about the list I like the list and who
else is on it and what's my position um
I think you're fourth fourth I might not
be the third but what if I do this hey
well then I'll do I'll do the listening
uh Dave
and is it better all the way up your leg
it is
thanks quite a question thank you well
you know I know that your legs are fine
they are thank you yeah I don't mean to
concentrate on your legs there's other
areas that I enjoy immensely as well wow
you're in the back of this thing thank
you thanks
when all girls school so it was kind of
fun because we played all the girls
parts and all the boys parts
I very often played a man
High School theater
I'll you I'll let you go as long as you
want
the boys
we wear uniforms did you wear a uniform
you still have your uniform I sure do
[Music]